my name is Ollie I'm 42 years old
and I plan to kill myself June 1st 2023.
I have tried to make my circumstances
better for several years
my daughter was kidnapped from me in
2017.
and every day has been worse
since then
I'm a hard worker
and everything I do seems to make it
worse so
I'm just kind of checking out last ditch
efforts to
see if I can make something change
between now and then
you've made efforts to
this is not like a rash decision this is
something you've been going through for
a while a long time a long time
um
the first time I considered
suicide seriously I mean I've always
thought about it but the first time I
considered it seriously and had a plan
and like a place
um a method all of those things uh was
five years ago
um and I allowed myself to be talked out
of it and um
it was based on kind of this idea you
know that my friend was going to still
be there he had been a mentor
um
and you know so he talked me out of it
he just come back to Portland uh and I
did and then he just kind of
you know I mean it's a heavy thing to
deal with
[Music]
um
and I don't even
I don't even hate him you know I was
angry with him for stopping me and then
um
you know if you save a life it's your
responsibility to care for it that's how
I feel and uh you can't just you know
pick up a you know injured kitten on the
street and then you know be like oh
sorry you're injured like it just
doesn't work and that's kind of what he
did
um so I just don't you know it's a man I
loved deeply uh and uh just nothing left
um
suicides a heavy thing for a person to
take on and deal with what tell me about
your childhood how did your life start
um
it was lonely I was an outsider I was a
loner I
had a significantly older uh sibling who
left at 17.
um and so we just really weren't close
and then my mother was always in her
room or at work she would come out to
yell at me sometimes she would let me
borrow her clothes sometimes
uh but when it came to raising me you
know if I needed somebody if I ever
needed an adult uh there really just
wasn't one
um I had a youth pastor
uh that I got kind of close with their
family
in middle school and then in high school
when I kind of started finding my voice
um
and I wasn't like questioning our faith
right I mean I was deep in that faith
but these atheist kids who I had made
friends with because we were in a play
together wrote a letter to the newspaper
and then all these Christian kids like
attacked them
and I just thought that was disgusting
right they were just you know I mean
just like the Christian kids like say
nerfingers and uh
I wrote a letter to the editor in
response
um and then that letter to the editor
got me kind of exiled from my youth
pastors family
um he told me a few years ago uh which
would have been 20 years after the fact
that I had challenged his faith
uh
I was 15.
you know he was he had gone to Seminary
so uh that was kind of the other set of
parents uh that came through I would
love to say my aunt uncle but they
weren't around either they were always
in the bedroom smoking weed so and your
father was right my father was a vet
um he was in Vietnam and uh
he when he came back from the Marines he
joined the Air Force and when he got
done with that
he converted to Judaism and went and
joined the Israeli National Army
so he uh there was a lot of War for him
and um
I just didn't uh you know I didn't spend
much time with him
um I was definitely poisoned against him
you know uh to think that he was nothing
but a just a gross drunk and he was
always going to disappoint me and I
think the thing is that had I not been
expecting those things and had my mother
not been expecting those things and
priming me to expect those things that
maybe it would have been a different
experience
um
now being homeless and having PTSD and
uh you know just wrestling with all of
these things
um
and meeting other people it uh
I feel like I've gotten to know my
father a little bit
as an adult and walked in his shoes
which um
is a Bittersweet sort of thing but yeah
just no parents
um how would you describe your childhood
in general
lonely
lonely I was always on the outside did
you feel loved never not ever
not ever and I used to talk to my best
friend about that you know uh we were 12
having conversations about that whether
we felt loved
um and you know her mother was a heroin
addict and a prostitute and like all
these things and she always felt like
she was loved or at least that's what
she said I'm not sure that her story
would be the same now
um but no never I never felt loved I
never felt uh protected
um
you know I never felt like there was
anyone who was going to stand up for me
or take my side
um I learned really really young to stay
the [ __ ] out of trouble because there
was no one coming for me
uh
and when I was in seventh grade my
friend got jumped in the hallway when we
were in Middle School
and the policy was that if it's fighting
they both get expelled and that was
[ __ ] she was jumped I was there I saw
it happen it was a group you know uh and
so I staged a sit-in in the principal's
office
and I was the only one who stayed
everybody else left uh and then I got
suspended and then my mother had to
bring me back to school and we sat in
the principal's office and all she did
was sit there and cry
you know that had been my kid I would
have stuck up for her like yeah we'll
take the suspension we're going to the
beach you know my mother sat there and
cried while the principal was like look
what you're doing to your mother so that
was uh and I had done something good you
know so like that was the first time
that it was really concrete I can't get
in any trouble and so I didn't
you know no adults no no safety net no
protection how far did you go in school
uh I've got a Bachelor's degree and a
year of Master's courses
um I graduated high school right before
my 19th birthday I took a year off
um and then switched schools
and then I started college several times
um I didn't know what I wanted to do but
then when I was 30
I just started taking like the pre-rec
courses that I didn't want to do you
know the math and the writing and all
that stuff and I remembered that I loved
math and so
um yeah but then that led to physics and
I so my degree
um is in Natural Sciences physics
medical physics is there a field you
want to go into I did um we were
studying free will
hmm yeah so
um I did research with these guys at
Stanford and uh that was one coma and
then
um I got into a doctoral program in
Atlanta and we were gonna do and it was
physics it was neurophysics and uh you
know what that industry is doing is
conducting tests
um on brain waves you know to see if we
can measure Free Will what's your what's
your view on Free Will I don't think we
have it
[Music]
yeah I I don't think that we have it
um but I struggle because
there are simple things you know there's
one thing I haven't answered for myself
if there's no free will how can I
memorize lines and go on stage and do a
play that seems incongruent for me and
then uh also these other little
decisions right like um do I want french
fries or chicken nuggets right and I so
it I feel like there's still a little
bit of room for some of those little
things but I think the big things I
don't think we're in control of that
at all
it's uh so you've had
other setbacks in your life but
since you've been an adult I mean I
would say that I was incurring PTSD as a
kid I mean the neglect
um it was a weird kind of neglect right
so like I was fat I was fat kid and uh
it was I was seven when I really started
getting fat we would rock up walk to the
grocery store and it was the 80s and uh
you know so candy bars were three for a
buck and sometimes they'd be on sale
four for a buck
and on the walk home you know my mom
would be like okay you can only have
three today because they were three for
a dollar right so I was fat I was
[ __ ] fat I was the fattest kid in my
class and then there was a boy uh who
was also fat but he wasn't quite as fat
as me you know and he had friends so
that makes a difference but it was so
weird because I was also going to school
without lunches
and so like all these kids and I knew we
didn't have food at home like that was
just always the case uh my mother had
credit card debt
um that she couldn't seem to stop having
and uh you know so I was fat and I was
going to school without lunch and these
people you know wanted to talk about how
much I ate and it was like I'm really
not eating anything like I don't know
you know I'm not sure how I'm sustained
at this weight considering you know um
and even now I look back on it like how
in the hell that worked but uh
yeah it was just weird so she kept me
like
looking okay enough so that it wouldn't
look like I was neglected you know you
can see kids and it's clear they're
probably neglected I was not that kid I
always looked healthy and sturdy
um
you know and I picked up this idea that
people needed to see us as okay and and
then when I was old enough to start kind
of changing my mind and putting my
clothes together the way I wanted
um I started you know as punk rock and
uh I went I spent like three four months
where I just didn't brush my hair
um I was just part of the thing I was
rocking you know
um
and so
I've kind of maintained that you know
like I've never fit in I've never looked
the same as everybody else even if I'm
trying to I don't and so I just kind of
said [ __ ] it you know I am who I am
um but that all stemmed
uh you know from this resistance to
looking like I had a better home life
than I did
do you consider yourself an outsider all
the time
yeah all the time even when I feel like
an Insider uh it doesn't seem to take
too long before I realize that I'm still
just kind of an observer
you've been in love before no never I
wouldn't say that I have
um
no
I um
I I have loved
uh very deeply
um
and I would say
I would say that
there was someone who tried with me once
for a second
um
but no
and it's hard for me like I don't uh
it's like I've got to be sending out
some kind of something you know
beforehand I yeah I don't I don't know
what it is
um
[Music]
because I'm not short on self-esteem
you know I feel like a pretty self-aware
person
um
[Music]
after the relationship with my youth
pastor's family I feel like that really
like influenced me to be drawn toward
married men in power right
um but for so long I wasn't a sexual
threat and so like having crushes on men
like that wasn't a problem uh you know
their wives didn't care forever I was a
kid and then I was fat so it didn't
matter you know so I just have crushes
on men like that
um
and
yeah just I don't think I
recognize it uh
you know when someone's interested in me
like legitimately
you have children yeah why not what
my daughter tell me about your daughter
um
she's 17.
and uh
she's a brilliant musician
um
and uh
the guy that I used to call my brother
um kidnapped her in 2017.
[Music]
what are the details of that didn't
happen
I uh I finished my degree in 2016 and
um
I was supposed to go to my doctoral
program in Atlanta so we packed up all
our stuff
and we got on a plane
um and it was a disaster from the
beginning when we got there the Airbnb I
had booked for a month it turned out
that guy wasn't supposed to be doing
that with his apartment
so we had taken the red eye we had our
cat we had all these oven-sized boxes we
hadn't eaten really you know we hadn't
had breakfast or anything
um so we got there and like you know
we're gonna walk to the store uh and
then before you know it there are angry
knocks on the door and it was the
management and they and we got we had to
go
um and all of it was downhill from there
uh I had no experience getting an
apartment in the real world
um I had seven thousand dollars I
thought that was going to be plenty I
had a month you know I didn't see
um uh but it didn't work out that way uh
and
so we ended up back in Portland
I did a year of this kind of joke
Masters program
um because I was able to like slide
under the door and get in so that made
it able for me to work
uh so I could teach for another year
and um
I was having a really hard time I mean
the the trajectory was I was going to
Stanford that was the plan and
um
and then it didn't happen I mean with
the program I had been in and the
research I had done I had a 50 chance of
going to Stanford grad school right
getting a PhD there 50 and that's
unheard of and it's and I still they
didn't do it and it's uh I've got PTSD I
freak out right so even though my team
loved me
um the administration did not
uh and that was how that went so
um and I just didn't my plan was [ __ ]
like I then we had gone to Atlanta it
had gone shitty and then it's like now
what what do I do right I had no idea
and when I don't have a plan I don't do
very well
um and so you know it was bad it was a
bad Academic Year like I was depressed
all year I was on the couch I was barely
going
um to classes uh I was smoking weed in
my office I mean you know like and
nobody noticed nobody noticed I had gone
from being this perfect like you know
physician or not physician physicist
sorry uh you know to being stoned like
all [ __ ] day nobody noticed and if
they did they didn't say anything
um so that just kind of added to it
and uh I knew my daughter was struggling
too
I was still trying to make sure that she
could get to all of her things you know
and have a good life but you know she
knew what was going on with me and
at the end of that year
um you know I was making plans I knew
that we couldn't stay in Portland
anymore I wasn't going to stay in that
master's program uh and so we were going
to get a job I was going to get a job at
Eastern Oregon we were going to go there
that fell through
um we were going to stay with my friend
in Eastern Washington uh but then her
daughter had an episode
um where she was threatening to hurt
herself but she drew a knife right and
it was my kid and her and all of a
sudden I hear my kids screaming for me
from the kitchen right which I want to
say I never would have screamed for my
mother in that situation
um so I go you know and I diffuse it and
you know make sure they're both okay
and then it was like we can't live here
you know I can't we can't live here
um so I called my brother
that [ __ ]
um
because he's got a big house you know he
did well for himself and uh and I
thought that he was
empathetic you know I mean he's in
safety he was a fireman like he's you
know Public Service whatever and my
brother right like that you're supposed
to be able to call your family
so we went there
um because he said we could go I told
him my mental health was bad I told him
it was worse than depression that I
needed some serious intervention that
you know was awful
we got there
and he talked me into Nevada's not going
to give you insurance you have to go
back to Oregon
and I was like I don't know you know I'm
a single mom I don't have a job Most
states are like here here's some
insurance not in Nevada they're not
going to do that so I believed him
and we made a plan and the plan was I
was going to drive back to Portland and
um initially I had three different
friends I was going to kind of hop
around with for two months while I did
an inpatient or an out intensive
outpatient program
um but when I got there uh my friend Pam
and her husband uh said just stay here
for that two months um so that was
really cool uh he's a therapist she's a
biologist she's had a lot of mental
health stuff with herself her family
um so they were good people to be with
so this was October
and then coming into Thanksgiving
um
my aunt who uh
she had gone to prison
um for drug related things
and I hadn't seen her I didn't see her
the whole time she was in prison I felt
really bad about it she got out and we
went and had coffee we were together for
45 minutes
she was preaching to me about how you
got to make good decisions you just got
to make the right decisions you know
don't do bad things make good decisions
I don't know what the [ __ ] she was
talking about like I'm not sure what
better decisions I can make I just
graduated with a 3.82 you know um we
joked about all the honor courts uh that
I wasn't going to make it across the
stage
um so good decisions I'm not sure how
much better they can get right uh and
then come to find out uh oh and I was
also trimming weed for my uncle right
um and their brother and sister so they
were talking and uh between them and my
brother and my daughter is at my
brother's uh in Nevada at this time they
decided that I was on meth
so uh
have you ever been on that never never
like I've never even tried it I've
always been terrified man and like none
of the health stuff but of getting
caught you know like I I just don't get
in trouble like I don't break the law I
don't Litter I don't you know what I
mean like I I'll jaywalk but that's
about it like uh so
I'm getting yelled at by him on the
phone and I know my daughter is right
there he's yelling at me with her right
there I can hear a crying
uh
you left your daughter and you abandoned
her to go do drugs with your friends
that's nope that's not that's not a
thing you know it's not what happened
uh and then like finally like he kind of
de-escalated and it turned into you
abandoned your daughter to go do yoga
with your friends in Portland which is
completely irrational
um
I went to Portland because they told me
I had to
and yoga was part of my healing uh
program
um and I went alone
and you know like it just
it was ridiculous and um they were
playing these phone games with my kid
where like I couldn't reach her for days
uh and eventually what it was was uh
don't you dare come back here don't even
think about coming to get saffron
uh he left me a voicemail
and
I can't even I mean I can't encapsulate
every
all of it
you know
um
but so
the result was
now I'm homeless
he's got my kid
I've been threatened not to go there
he works for [ __ ] area 51. you know
so it's like he's in charge I don't have
any rights I didn't like
the thought didn't even occur to me
to call the police where I was
because it didn't even occur to me that
that was a kidnapping
and it
took a couple years
and somebody else in therapy saying to
me you know someone can't just take your
kid that's kidnapping
and it is
uh and he had done that
with his wife's sister's kids too
and you know I mean I don't know if she
was on meth I don't know
um that's what they told me but they
told a lot of people that about me as
well which just wasn't
the truth and so
uh you know her
his wife's sister was staying with them
and they kept her two boys
right and it just that should have been
a red flag when I heard that story that
should have been a red flag but what I
heard was you know oh she just abandoned
them here
you know because she cared about the
drugs more and then they did that to me
you know so like I uh
you know I just have a tendency to trust
the wrong
people
um
have you had a string of bad luck
throughout your life yeah I would say
that you consider yourself an unlucky
person I think it weighs out I feel like
it evens out I've had a lot of beautiful
experiences too yeah yeah I don't hate
life I definitely don't hate myself you
know I don't hate people
um
but to be considering suicide
yeah you know is that's that's a big
decision yeah I think
I mean could you be uh borderline
personality disorder or something like
that you know um that was something that
we were looking at and uh that we had
talked about
um my therapist and I like kind of at
the beginning you know and then looking
back and what I really think
um I I one therapist said to me that
borderline is just untreated PTSD I
definitely can identify with that my
PTSD is not okay
um
borderline personality is associated
with this lack of an identity you know
and I had I kind of felt like that when
I was going through it at first like I
didn't know who I was like I was
stealing my identity from other people
but I've always had a really strong
sense of who I am I know who I am
um you know I uh I know I guess rather
than giving it a name yeah just maybe
it's just a mental disorder that is
making you consider suicide
sure rather than
I mean losing your daughter is horrible
yeah there's no there's no yeah no way I
can come up with a reason why that's
okay but
it doesn't warrant a suicide oh no it's
gotten way worse it's just been worse I
mean it's all just like snowballed you
know it just keeps getting worse because
I mean what he did to me was he made me
homeless
and he stole my daughter right so he put
me in this position where I was
believing what he was saying to me that
I needed to get my [ __ ] together you
know so that I could go get my daughter
back well he's not a [ __ ] social
worker and he's not a judge I didn't
need to do any of that [ __ ] what I
needed to do was call the [ __ ] police
and I didn't know that you know but um I
was stuck in that narrative how many
years has she been gone five all right
yeah
um
yeah
and uh
she's not with them anymore
um you know he's just he needs to look
like a hero but he got rid of her as
soon as he could and I've spoken to her
since she's yeah
um we we were talking all the time it
was never the arrangement that she
wasn't supposed to be with me so I mean
we were talking all the time that's why
when they would play the phone games I
would get really concerned because we
were talking every day we had a constant
text conversation going on me and my
daughter
um and talking on the phone a lot uh and
you know she
has taken in all of the stuff that they
said
without being able to actually get my
side of it right I mean talking on the
phone with someone texting with someone
you're not seeing how they're living
you're just you know with them in that
moment and so you know he was accusing
me of all kinds of things you know
saying that I wasn't going to treatment
or that I had dropped treatment you know
um and I had gone to a couple treatment
programs that didn't work so I made a
different treatment plan you know and um
and it was effective so like uh she was
watching all of this and then as soon as
I could get her out of there
um I tried to get her and then that
didn't work out
um and so she ended up at her dad's and
I enlisted him I called him up and was
like hey you need to come up we need we
need some help and you need to step up
you've done nothing this whole time and
so uh he did and then she spent a
horrible [ __ ] year with him
and then uh
she ended up now she's living uh at that
place that I didn't want us to live
because
um the daughter
has some violent things
um you know but yeah we've been on the
phone here and there
uh
and it's a weird thing to navigate
because like
I don't want to be pushy
and I don't know really how to be pushy
um
you know and everything I do
makes it worse and she doesn't want to
hear my side you know she doesn't want
to see it either you know I mean one of
the arguments from my brother was that
like they couldn't get a hold of me or
whatever or like you know oh we've been
calling you a bunch and we can't get a
hold of you and I'm like that's [ __ ]
because you know every time I try to
talk to you you don't want to talk to me
and uh I can show you the phone records
you know like please let me allow me to
show you the phone records uh nobody
wants to see them so um
yeah
um
it's been it's just been
you know this list of people just making
assumptions about what's going on in my
life because they're not talking to me
passing my daughter around
um I went and tried to get the police
when I found out where she was
um and even the police
by then and had she been in Oregon at
the time
um it she would be with me right now she
would be with me right now
um
because that's my kid you know I talked
to police before I went and tried to get
her and the Washington police uh
operated in a different way
um
but so
on top of this uh have come the
challenges of being homeless which
I'm not cut out before it's not a thing
I ever did
um I it's I've never had a rough life
you know I uh they called me the [ __ ]
of Reason in high school that was my
nickname because when they were thinking
of all I hung out with the white trash
kids that's you know we were the poor
white trash kids whenever they were
coming up with something dumb that they
were gonna do I was like hold on let me
tell you why you shouldn't do those
things and why you don't want to go to
juvie if you're so reasonable why did
you not find a solution to this that's
what I want to know right just get a job
and get a roof over your head I've tried
I've tried it I've had 36 different jobs
and volunteer gigs in the last three
years and so why do you not last what's
that why do you nuts
I don't last because uh I I freak out
right so
um and and for different reasons I
didn't last at the middle school in
Arizona because they were giving
detention to Children speaking Spanish
in school and that's unconstitutional I
wasn't going to stick around for that
um I you know I tried to like make a
difference and stick around but they
weren't having it so
um
you know but other things like I've
tried to just get stupid little jobs
that are just gonna pay the bills so I
can just make it happen until I can you
know do whatever else and you know
the hard thing about getting a job
outside of my field is that when you get
a job and you're an entry-level person a
lot of those places are dysfunctional
they want to treat you like [ __ ] and I
don't have the Constitution for that
either you know I mean I'm used to
sitting at the table with doctors and
and physicists like and and sharing that
way
um and so to go into a place where
you know you're just expected to kowtow
uh and literally break your back you
know I mean I've been I've also I've got
these physical disabilities as well
um and I mean uh uh veil in in
California Nevada that Resort uh they
were like we're not We're Not Gonna you
know
um give you any accommodations you can
either do the job or you can't is it
Vail in Colorado uh there's another one
yeah there's uh that's Veil color yeah
there's one is it fail Vale Resorts and
they own the one that I was at
yeah so they might be the same people
okay
um but so I've tried I've tried a lot
you know I went to another one uh where
I was just kind of working as a
receptionist and then our first payday
comes and my check doesn't show up well
I needed to check so I could put the gas
in the car to get to work otherwise I
wasn't going to be able to get there so
I had no choice I had to call her right
because the check didn't clear I
couldn't get to work
um and you know let her know hey the
check didn't clear I just can't put gas
in do you know what's going on you know
and she was shitty about it and I knew
she was being shitty about it because
she gave me the same speech that she had
told me she had given other employees
who were being shitty asking her about
their paychecks you know so uh that was
it for me you're gonna [ __ ] with my
money then I may not get it then I'm out
you know and then it turned out that
there was a problem with the paychecks
that day right so it's like my
I know I'm the problem right I don't
have the ability to get through those
small they're small right and I don't
have anyone in my life who I can go to
and be like hey this happened you know
so they can just give me a hug and calm
me down right and a lot of times that's
all I need and I'd be fine so you know I
go to these places I keep getting more
and more hurt when I was working at
Mammoth uh Resort uh I found out I was
gonna need a knee replacement
um because my body's already my joints
are kind of weak and they had me doing
this job in the same position all day
every day right and so okay great and
they're like how about workers comp and
I was like sure let's look into that
well then I get overwhelmed because now
we're talking about me one little person
with no family no friends nothing taking
on this huge [ __ ] Resort and they're
gonna do everything they can to make me
look like a liar right and that's just
true that's just what they do and so
I don't have the ability to get through
these things I just don't have it I
think that I could you know if I could
get the treatment that I needed right
still do you have a bit of a victim
mentality me yeah
I think that's where I'm going and I've
never been that way I've never been that
way and I don't I don't like it I don't
like feeling like a victim and I don't
like perceiving myself that way I just
wonder if there's another solution
rather than suicide for you me too and
that's you know that was why I gave
myself a year you know
um
and and at the beginning of that year it
was kind of a Whimsical thing you know I
was feeling better I had spent the the
some time down in the desert with some
friends and uh you know for months and
we have a little Community down there
and I do great we clean the hot springs
together
um and they're kind and you know we form
a little community and it works and
after spending those months with them
um and feeling like it was time to be
better
um
I knew about programs up in uh Mammoth
that you know would get me housing and
that would help me apply for cash
benefits
um and all that stuff and so I decided
to go that route uh and because I've
been spending the last three years just
like running around trying to find a job
and put a roof over my head right and uh
so I thought okay I'm just gonna take
the benefits I'm gonna go and I'm gonna
apply for the benefits I'm gonna get the
housing and just rest and give myself a
year you know I've got doctors who will
say that I'm disabled uh my psychiatrist
would say forever
um my current doctor would say 12 months
uh and
so that was what I was trying to do
right so um I told myself you know what
you're going to give yourself a year to
figure this life thing out and if all
else fails you can always kill yourself
June 1st you know so it wasn't really
like uh I'm definitely gonna kill myself
June 1st it was a
let's take a year you know take a year
take a breath see if we can make it work
and
once again just nothing you know and
just it just
has been this weird
[ __ ] experience
you know of hitting my head up against a
wall and being treated weird by people
like I don't I just feel like
I just entreated weird uh and I
you know I don't know
I don't know
um you know without maybe sounding
conceited uh you know I I feel like
people are intimidated
um I feel like people change when they
find out what my education is I feel
like people don't trust these [ __ ]
teeth
this is what they see
you know and like
you know it just it
now that it's happened to me so many
times
it's going to take some serious slate
cleaning to be able to walk into a place
and not just anticipate that that's
what's gonna happen
you know
so
um
the last time I tried to work
was for a camp on the coast of
California
and um you know the the cool thing about
outdoor education and I'm so grateful to
have found it
um not only because I'm totally cut out
for that work that's the exact job I was
meant to do but they house you they feed
you you know you go and it's you're just
there you are you're home and you're
working and it's all of it
um and so I went and they housed me with
two 18 year olds who smoke weed and
drink
and I mean I'm a teacher I teach middle
school kids I am not going to be a
roommate with you know minors doing that
sort of stuff I'm not all right with it
um and it just seemed kind of odd to me
because they know that those kids are
smoking in their property right
um and so I was I didn't freak out I
thought I did a really good job I went
you know and I just said hey I feel a
little bit uncomfortable about the age
you know do you mind if if I just move
over to this place they were super cool
about it
I thought they really liked me
um they uh one of the main guys had me
take his daughter for her birthday night
hike you know uh and
so I really thought that things were
going well we had to kind of keep
putting stuff off because of covid and
so I was just doing odd jobs and working
in the garden
and then finally we had our first day of
training
and I was hired as a leader I was in a
leadership position it's my experience
that if you're a leader showing up with
other leaders you know there's certain
things you come to the table with you're
not you know I mean yeah you're trying
to learn their system you're trying to
show them what you know
and I thought I was real quiet all day I
tried not to Pepper in too much because
I'm trying to take in the information
and after that one day of training I'm
on the floor in my boss's office crying
while he's telling me every single thing
I did wrong that day and the more I
cried the more Angry he got you know
like it was he needed it he needed an
outlet clearly
um but those are the kinds of situations
I end up in I don't [ __ ] understand
um and
I don't
my capacity for it is just gone
I want to work I want to be working I
should be working 60 70 hours a week I
should be out in the field with kids I
should be doing those things I'm you
know uh and
my body is there something that's
keeping that from happening my body
um I need two knee Replacements I broke
a leg two years ago and they put in is
there something about your personality
that kind of yeah absolutely personality
the kids love me right the kids love me
in fact
um you know I'm usually the favorite and
I actually don't like that uh at my
second Camp I worked at we were kind of
all the favorites and that is the ideal
uh you know
um but yeah my personality I freak out I
just like if the trust is weird
um or if I can tell somebody's being
insincere
um and then I'm just kind of left with
them by surprise uh I freak out I freak
out and you know I um
I recognize that I do it but I can't
stop it from happening so uh you know
that's why I keep trying to fix it
because I don't want to freak out you
know and I'm sure that freaking out with
those adults makes that makes them worry
that I'm gonna freak out with the kids
right and there's something that happens
to me when I step into that role and I
get those little ducklings
there's just not I'm not gonna freak out
you know I mean you could
shoot a kid in line behind you right and
I'm not gonna freak out I'm gonna defuse
the situation right it's a totally
different side
um that brings out all of the stuff
about me that's awesome
um but so how serious are you about
suicide oh I'm done June 1st yeah I'm
done that's that's the date you've
stopped this out what's that you
considered how to do it and all that oh
yeah I've got everything everything is
ready and and yeah I was gonna do it on
August 8th
and again let myself [ __ ] be talked
out of it
um and that'll be another person I never
talked to again uh but
I can't
the more I try to help myself the worse
my situation gets
you know
um it's really nice that people want to
help
but what it's like you're putting a
Band-Aid on a broken leg right it's not
those little things don't
do a whole lot
um
[Music]
driving down here with you
and seeing these folks
and just meeting folks
who also are in this lifestyle
um
I don't think anybody belongs here
but I would have a lot easier time
understanding why I'm here had I been a
drug addict or prostitute or like you
know
beaten and molested right like I mean I
was horribly neglected but you know
I thought that I kind of made my own way
like it's I'm still
very much in shock
that I live in a car
you know that I can't even put gas in
and that it shouldn't even be starting
anymore
um and so
have you seen psychologist therapists
yeah
yeah a lot what have they told you
the last one just kept telling me that I
was right you know she kept like
you know she would reinforce this idea
that I hadn't done anything incorrect in
those situations
um and one of the last times I sat down
with her you know I was really upset and
I said what I need you to help me do is
understand where I'm wrong here and how
I can improve like I don't need you to
tell me that I'm awesome you know I need
you to help me work on this [ __ ] that's
why I'm coming here and you know she
told me in the next session that when I
approached her that way and again I was
sitting on the floor I sat on the floor
a lot
um
she was sitting in a chair I was sitting
on a floor and I was crying and I was
very you know upset like I need you I
need you to help me fix this and figure
out what the problem is
and the next session we had together she
told me that she felt
I forget the word she used
helpless Frozen
or something
you know and it's like you've you
couldn't handle me when I was in a
crisis you're my therapist
um
and so that's just kind of you know and
the list of those people uh is very long
um people who can't help me when I'm in
a crisis and it's just so [ __ ] up like
I don't I mean I don't understand you
know I don't I'm not a violent person
I've never been a violent person you
know
um I
I have emotions and I'm not allowed to
have them you know they freak people out
so you know it doesn't feel in my body
like I'm doing anything different when
I'm crying about something than when I
see somebody else crying about something
but for whatever reason you know and I
don't know if it's this expressive face
um I don't know you know
I mean I know I'm intense I know I'm
intense do you have friends no I
wouldn't say well maybe one
maybe one
yeah
yeah but no
um what mistakes do you think you've
made what if you had your life to live
all over again what would you have done
differently
um I never would have gone to my
brothers ever not ever
um I would have called the police
that was your biggest setback yeah
yeah I would have called the police
absolutely
um
you know I but mostly
I don't have a ton of regrets because
I try to embrace things and I try to
fix them when they're broken you're
certainly intelligent thank you yeah but
clearly there's something that's not
right working out yeah in your life
because right you're constantly coming
up against
yeah all the time constantly and that's
you know that's
what I've tried to figure out
you know
and it's
[Music]
I just I don't understand right and it's
easy to fixate on things like if I get
these teeth fixed maybe my face won't be
so scary
you know
um and maybe I won't seem so intense
your face isn't scary
I don't think so but people are afraid
of my face you know and
I can't imagine that people are afraid
of your face perhaps your personality
repels people or something like that you
should see me it changes I mean my my
boss
um at my second camp
he told me at the beginning he said what
we need
you know when when you're happy
your face is up here when you're not
happy your face is down here
and we need those faces to come closer
together right we need your faces to
look
closer together
and I was like yes thank you you know
and I remember how surprised they both
were that I was into that feedback do
you have intense
yeah changes from happy to sad or angry
to yeah you do yeah and then sad is not
a thing I'm going to give everybody
because it's so vulnerable
um and so
uh but the personality you're showing
here in this talk is not who you are at
all times no I mean this is uh this is
neutral me and this is probably pretty
you know I'm pretty easy going like
happy person
um there's a darker side to you yeah
absolutely not and everybody has it yeah
yeah everybody has it
um mine just only picks on me you know
and but so the thing is like
ultimately I've been going through this
for so long and really it would take
days for us to go through all of the
things
because I know the only common
denominator is me right so the only
thing I can fix is me and that's what
I'm trying to do but all those things
keep getting [ __ ] so like uh
and I'm gonna lose my train of thought
oh right so
if I had been diagnosed with cancer
right
uh
and I'm going to say three years I'm
going to say it's been three years that
I'm [ __ ] done I'm over it I want out
right uh and if I had had a cancer
diagnosis three years ago and was still
dealing with it and it was getting worse
I would have already been offered the
option
you know to take my own life and uh you
know there are places in Europe where
mental health is a thing that they
accept and so uh you know for for
euthanasia and
and that's how I feel about it I am not
I mean I've been homeless in the
wilderness that is where I go I can't
handle other people I don't trust other
people
um you know and I it's it's terrifying
uh
I was
[Music]
so
I feel my mental health declining I feel
my decision making getting worse
and
on top of that
you know I'm losing my legs because
there's nothing I can do
uh to fix them where I'm at and so
with the mental health and
um
the
physical health and the employment
catastrophes and the fact that I just
can't go anywhere he went out
being [ __ ] or or freaking out because
I think I'm getting [ __ ]
it's been too long and it just keeps
getting worse
you know and
so it's it's not
it's not like that's what I want
for myself
you know like
that's not all what I want for myself
I mean I uh
it's funny you know I always thought
that I would marry a pastor
and have a bunch of kids
and now
it's like
anyone kind of handsome with an interest
and a little bit of Hope
you know and my brain is going ha maybe
you're going to fall in love with this
one
and that's dumb
and I and it just finds me in these
shitty situation and so
I I can't
anymore
um
I just I can't do it
um and it's a suicide yeah how would you
do it
um there are a lot of uh things that
I've thought about I was originally
going to drown
uh in Oregon
and then
um I was gonna jump in uh up near Tahoe
and then
um
I thought about trying to get my hands
on some Fentanyl
and uh there's a boy I know in Bishop
who
um I've only I've met him because we go
to the same place to get showers right
and I'll give him cigarettes sometimes
and
I got brave enough to ask him you know
because I had seen him before I'd talked
to him before
um and it was just such a wishy-washy
you know ah no I don't think I do and oh
yeah I got some right now you know and
then he said something about I don't
even know what it looks like and so I
was like okay no
even though I know if I actually got
some fentanyl you know that it could do
it easy
um I can't guarantee that that's what
I'm gonna get and it's terrifying to try
to get it so uh I've done a lot of
research online
um
and uh so ultimately hanging
um
is what I have set my my sights on
poisoning and hanging uh but legal
poisoning
um just so that I can sedate myself
enough
so
in June 1st June 1st 2023
what could happen between now and June
1st it might change your plan
you know
um
all I can do
is wait for the miracle right like
Leonard Cohen said
but
I mean because the more I fight the
worse it gets
so
you know I just uh
I mean I I don't I don't even know right
like uh
tomorrow morning I'll get on the train
and I'll get on a bus and I'll go back
to Bishop to a car that doesn't have any
gas in it
and uh
you know
and that
there's just no plan and like
I know I'm [ __ ] up right and
and I accept it
but like
I didn't do it you know I didn't do this
to myself and I've worked so hard
to be in a different position you know I
mean I should be
working at a university somewhere
and
I just I don't
understand you know I don't understand
what it is
and I've tried so hard to change that
and uh
you know I mean they're just
so many challenges being homeless and
trying to put [ __ ] together you know
like you can't get an ID without an
address right and so when I lost my
wallet that he created all these crazy
[ __ ]
and like
I just um
the system is not meant for any of us to
get out of it
once you're in it you're not supposed to
weave it
and
I don't I don't
I've never begged for things
my whole life I've never begged for
things
and I'm in this position
you know where to even [ __ ] get
anywhere I have to beg for the most
basic things tampons for [ __ ] sake
like
and
that's not what I went to school for man
you know
that's not what I went to school for
even before I was in school the [ __ ] I
had was mine you know
and it doesn't
matter what it is anymore you know it
doesn't
matter if it's my job or my bank account
or my [ __ ] body
if somebody wants it
my daughter
they can just take it I'm totally
powerless I have nothing you know I
don't have a tribe
I don't have anyone to call
you know like
it's easy to give people good news
um
and I had set my date for August 8th I
was done I was [ __ ] done I had
everything ready I was putting together
uh my best friend in high school and I
we used to make these just ridiculous
books for each other just as stupid
stuff like a Dust Bunny taped on one
page you know
and I was putting one of those together
for my daughter
um
and like you know putting all the
passwords to like
music and pictures and things so she can
access them
and it was a reflex it was a reflex my
[ __ ] I was on the phone with someone
who's being shitty to me and the first
thing that my brain did like I didn't
even think about it was hit the button
and call this dude Tim
and he talked me out of it
and it wasn't even a split-second thing
you know I was planning it out like that
was a couple of weeks right I was like
August 8th that's what I'm doing
and I let him [ __ ] talk me out of it
and all a guy has to do is pretend that
he's interested in me right so no more
of that
um
I was ready
you know I was [ __ ] ready I was ready
I was at peace I felt okay about it
um
you know there are things about knot
placement
that are really important
um
because you want to cut off certain
things and preserve others
you know
um
I had the place I mean I had it all
worked out I felt good I was at peace
and I even feel like it would be better
for her
you know
to just
have some finality
I guess
um
I don't buy that suicide is the answer
but I understand you're feeling like it
is I wish it wasn't and I I wish it
wasn't I mean I look at you and you're
intelligent you're healthy I'm not
healthy
I look healthy
I'm not healthy and that's part of the
[ __ ] man is that this is It's So
invisible you know so people are
surprised what's your health problem
um my legs don't work so uh my spine is
collapsing too so uh in my neck I don't
have most of my discs are are completely
deteriorated right so I get this uh you
walked fine when I was wrong I did but
you saw my orthotic right
um
I am I'm walking fine and um and that's
what sucks right if I had access to the
treatment and the surgeries and the
physical therapy that I need
um these wouldn't be issues I also have
a
lumbosacral issue and so I can't feel
this whole hip right and so yeah I'm
walking fine
um and I do my own kind of stuff to make
sure that's going to happen
um
but I'm these problems are big so
they're invisible but they're big and
they're getting worse and they're just
going to keep getting worse I'm not
gonna live without my legs
not gonna do it
um
so you know uh
but I do I look healthy and I sound
healthy right I sound normal I don't
sound like a person who's gonna wig out
on you for no reason
don't try me though
no really don't like
yeah all right well I hope you
have a change of heart I hope something
comes into your life that changes your
whole attitude about things
hope to hear from you on June 2nd
[Laughter]
I just got a feeling there's there's
another solution
been looking for it for years I don't
know what it is
so I'm open to ideas
you know you're smart enough to find one
what's that you're smart enough to find
one I you would think so but me on my
own is not enough I mean that's what
I've been doing for 42 years you know I
don't um
I don't have it so you know whatever it
is it's missing
I don't have it I haven't found it and
not willing to be stripped anymore bear
of what dignity I have left
all right thank you so much for sharing
your story thank you Mark
I wish you the best of luck
thank you